welcome back to new rock stars what if
episode 8 showed us a universe where
ultron won and just like when you give a
mouse a cookie ultravision decided that
one universe just wasn't going to be
enough i mean just one seriously that's
just an appetizer so he brings the beat
down to watu and berate him for just
sitting back and watching as timelines
just go awry like does this mean
ultravision was right do we have like an
ultravision killmonger situation not
really he's a terrible person this is
rogue theory the show that where we
pitch the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love my name is mt and
growing rogue with me today and
appearing in her own final form it's
jessica clemens what's going on jose hey
can't wait to be split in a half like
thanos by ultravision
oh my god he can take it he can get it
he can get it he can get it he's hot as
hell and i love a villain and i love a
villain you do love a villain and hidden
away in her own siberian bunker it's
prolific twitch streamer angelica trey
what's going on angelica
hey yeah it's me out here in very
secretive russia right
there secrets are the past times i've
always meant to tell you that your
background looks exactly like a hydra
base so like this is oh that's what i
designed it for so and finally we booted
up our own evil artificial intelligence
it's off-screen producer brandon my
brother what's going on brad oh beep
beep boop boop destroy all humans let's
do this
ready to comply ready to comply this
episode of what if found watu suddenly
on the defensive against a powerful
fully stoned ultravision not stoned that
way kids i mean it's less fun stone
determined to wipe out all of the
multiverses with only one episode left
in the series i have to ask all of you
how the hell is this thing going to end
like what are your final predictions for
the series like what is uatu the
watchers plan and how will the what if
series set up the next events in the
movies and like what will we explore in
the second season of the series too okay
no i'm just so what i'm trying to do is
tie in
natasha still with
zola
and so what i think is going to happen
moving forward i don't know if this is
going to be a season two arc or if this
will be the last episode because this
show has turned from episodic into
cereal now right like it's it's all
connecting which is awesome
but i think that what's gonna happen is
so
ultron has a taste of all of this power
now and i think ultron
is going to go around to all these
different universes he's going to start
gobbling them up turns into galactus
because we've had a couple
like hungry quotes
um and
yeah he kind of resembled galactus for a
second there so he's basically going to
be
galactus and then with the help of watu
strange supreme is going to
be guided into fighting
this galactus ultron and what's going to
end up happening is somehow natasha is
going to come in and maybe like zola's
zolabot is going to figure out how to
connect
somehow between these universes or maybe
they trap them in a particular
universe with them and
going to disseminate the virus and
the universe multiverse will be saved
interesting so an ultron galactus oh
yeah okay that's my long-winded just
windy theory there
that is certainly rogue i like the idea
of the ultron galactus because like like
you said we did have that visual in the
episode that was 100
a galactus easter egg like i could not i
cannot think of anything more galaxy
than biting an entire galaxy like
that's a lot of galactus
i was like he's eating a planet universe
so i was like i don't know what's going
on here
i imagine all the mcu fans were just
going wait a minute when they saw that
oh yeah i was freaking out it was quite
intense i really liked during their
fight um they they put in their like
kind of kirby crackle the little dots uh
in the league oh my god yeah in the in
the blast i was like yes
of the marvel comics yeah galactus and
the watcher they all came around from
jack kirby and it was like cool to see
that like homage to him i think that
what we're heading to i think angelica's
totally right like we're getting
together the super squad of elements
from like each little multiverse we're
obviously gonna see like captain carter
again
right uh she's got to come back this
tentacle monster
that's got to play a role somehow right
maybe that
if it's uh schumacher right maybe it's
capable of stopping
this uh ultravision with all the stones
right maybe they need to bring that
thing in or maybe strange supreme
because he
absorbed part of those tentacles becomes
the monster himself and like sacrifices
himself that way to destroy uh
ultravision but there's also this like
rumor out there that captain carter's
gonna show up in like the multiverse of
madness so i think this is
i think this series might somehow tie
into like the multiverse of madness the
next doctor strange film somehow like
some of these characters could
transition over into that movie
transition into live action in some sort
of strange way uh i don't know but i do
love this idea of uh
going to each of the kind of timelines
we've seen and picking the last ones
because you have like party thor will be
great to bring in because it seems like
the thor's and all the other multiverses
are you sure about that i mean i think
he's i think he's ready to do it you
know he learned a lesson in his he
learned a lesson he literally well he
taught a lesson he taught a lesson to
captain marvel but then he learned and
he fixed the leaning tower of pisa well
we're also do we know where he is after
uh ultravision showed up
well that's that's a great question
jessica because he also couldn't i was
wondering that too because this episode
kind of started in a different spot and
it was like to
what happened to the oahuatu who saw and
was like wait what and then kind of
jumps over and he's like i'm going to
tell you another story now it's like
wait what about what was happening over
there
that that that's a good point jessica i
don't know what if if thor knows what's
up or or what well i mean simple
solution to that he could have just been
beamed up like in the middle of when
that happened and then instead of ultra
well ultravision didn't have all the
stones then he was just i'm here to
attack so he probably was like i'm not
gonna mind whatever that was and i'm
gonna continue on
boy i sure do love killing um he was on
a mission sorry go kill him again yeah
here i go killing again
so brandon you're saying that uwatu is
gonna cherry pick each of the the heroes
yeah i think so like even you said like
that that natasha we saw in this last
episode she survives with the zola bot
uh and now she has she has a shield too
she's got the red guardian shield and it
seemed like all the other natashas that
we've seen have died so
i i think
enough of each hero's been killed off in
different universes uh that you could
kind of put together a team but there's
still ego out there too who has his
peter quill battery right right he might
show up because he got he got his face
blown off uh in one of these timelines
so he's like wait what what's going on
there's so many different players that
were introduced in this series that
could just all just come to a head in
this final episode like so you guys like
see like another like sort of infinity
war type scenario but like a
multi-infinity war in this episode i'm
imagining all this right now it's
absolutely chaos in my head i'm
imagining like zombies clashing with the
you know all the ultron ultron
it's really chaotic in my mind right now
but i'm kind of digging it so yeah i
could see that what a chaotic theory do
you think that like so we saw that
zombies thanos had like a full infinity
gauntlet or was about to make one
because the last stone was coming to him
is his
use of the infinity stones as strong as
like ultravisions like are all infinity
stones equal when they're brought into
like this multiverse space that kind of
looked like look it reminded me of like
the library scene
interstellar you know when matthew
mcgonagay's just kind of like floating
in that the weird like
space-time library i've never seen that
movie
are you asking if infinity stones cross
different universes than their original
universe are you asking
yeah kind of because ultravision was
able to take his stones
out of his universe and into this like
you know into any other timeline
multiverse and fight with them so and we
know zombie thanos has like a full set
of stones too
is are his just as powerful as like
ultravisions if they met in like a weird
space outside of their own timelines i
feel like it does matter
who is in control of the infinity stones
in order to use it and the way that
ultravision
ultra vision ultra
ultron vision whatever
ultron so the way that ultron actual
ultron destroyed uh thanos was so easy
and quick that i think it's like it's
it's apparent brutal that power that he
holds is stronger than what thanos could
have with the stones especially because
like we're working with like
a mechanical
sentient being that has one purpose
versus uh
thanos who does have one purpose but is
still
the closest closer to human than what
like
ultron i'm just trying to get to
retirement that's yeah he's like i just
want to rest and retire because he's
still like
yeah so i think
ultron using those infinity stands is
like tenfold where thanos wouldn't be i
don't think it's gonna be a war only
because i don't think
the zombies don't really have
the if they fought ultron's army they
would also want to eat the current
avengers that we're working with as well
so it's like if the zombie zombies did
show up they would be very
counterproductive
but
that's in chaos it would be too much it
would be so much and then we also don't
know in that timeline if they did or
were able to reverse everything that
happened not reverse but cure those that
were infected so just like how with thor
we don't know if thor died fighting
ultron before he got the stones and just
like with the zombies we don't know if
they actually got were able to succeed
in getting rid of them and finding a
cure it won't be a giant war but it will
be what brandon said them cherry-picking
each hero from each timeline to come
back and they're going to create their
own version of the avengers and i think
we are definitely getting that because
we saw that little piece with black
widow wearing the um what i think i i
think i saw in the teaser um her red
guardian shield so i was like oh okay so
she is going to be cherry-picked into
the avengers with her dad shield oh
cute
cute
we'd love to see it okay what if what if
season two
they bring in keanu and john connor and
they fight all of the old genres
yeah and they're all fighting the bots
it's every famous character that fought
robots
in any piece of literature
does that count for like the terminator
yes oh yeah definitely captain marvel
doing dirty on the terminator like that
right rude
she's real heavy on the 90s references
i was wondering what happened to the
what you know you angelica you mentioned
like the zombie scarlet witch what
happened to the the scarlet witch in
this like ultravision timeline i don't
think she was does she ever go good
i don't think she was oh i thought she
wasn't maybe strong enough maybe it
wasn't do you think ultron like killed
her off like immediately because he used
them you know in the film to like get
what he needed
maybe he used him here and then just
like wiped him out himself like i don't
need you guys yeah i know the series of
events is it can vary between these
universes so obviously you know just
we're going off of some of the parallel
timelines we've seen but scarlet witch
hasn't fully come into her own yet you
know like that wanda vision
finale just yet um where she was
actually truly coming into her powers
um so i think that she probably just got
wiped out i don't think she was strong
enough yet you know i still have my
theories too just with uh with that the
episode before last with thor
and how
him and captain marvel were struggling
so much i feel like thor would have been
wiped out by ultron as well so
i don't know or ultravision right well
yeah he destroyed asgard so thor is
probably on asgard when he i think we
saw when he was yeah right before he
launched the nukes i think we saw like
mjolnir like sitting there on the ground
uh and there was like a body slumped
over like right before tony oh yeah with
all those guys oh cause they were
fighting they killed a man yeah yeah
yeah but party thor's still alive baby
and he's ready to fight oh i know what i
believe i'm not gonna be helpful well
how did party no did party thor survive
because
he was really struggling with captain
marvel right well we we have seen him in
promo material with i believe dr strange
so i think that he does survive well we
see we see the cut the cut of him
talking to what we think is doctor
strange
i hate marble teasers for this
i'm like oh no they're definitely
talking you have to see both their
bodies in the same damn shot but i do
think it's the scene where he's like
zombies wild we still haven't seen that
part these were all amazing theories so
for that everyone gets five thousand
points oh baby a lot of points that's a
lot of points well that is it for our
first topic of the video and we do have
some theories about how this thanos got
all of this bling but first by the time
you're watching this there's probably a
brand new venom inspired shirt available
from our merch partners at epic hero
like most of their stuff there will be a
limited supply so you should grab one
really quickly and you can still check
out the shanxi what if and loki inspired
designs available at new
rockstarsmerch.com it's a great way to
support our channel and let your inner
nerdum shine through but before we
continue we do want to thank our friends
at upstart for sponsoring this video if
you are carrying a credit card balance
month after month it can feel like a
never-ending cycle of debt like
physically being stuck on a peloton bike
forever so upstart is a fast and easy
way to pay off your debt with a personal
loan all online so whether it's paying
off credit cards consolidating high
interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a billion people have
used upstart to get one fixed monthly
payment upstart knows that you're more
than just your credit score and is
expanding access to affordable credit
unlike other lenders upstart considers
your income and current employment to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
with a five minute online rate check you
can see your rate up front for loans
between one thousand to fifty thousand
dollars and you can receive funds as
fast as one business day after accepting
your loan so find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today when
you go to upstart.com rogue that's
upstart.com
rogue and don't forget to use our url to
let them know that we sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application so go to upstart.com
rogue
but guys there's nothing sexier than
confidence and bluetooth can help give
you confidence where it counts you know
down there
stop ft okay bluetooth is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost and you can take
them anytime day or night just take them
responsibly please so you can plan ahead
or be ready whenever an opportunity
arises you lucky duck the process is
simple sign up at bluetooth.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved
you'll receive her prescription within
days so you don't have to wait and the
best part it's all done online so no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacy and blue chews tablets are
made in the usa and prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discrete
package so if you can benefit with from
extra confidence when it's time to
perform blue chew can help and we've got
a special deal for our listeners try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code rogue at checkout just pay five
dollars shipping that's bluechu.com
promo code rogue to receive your first
month for free visit bluetooth.com for
more details and important safety
information and we thank bluechu for
sponsoring this video all right gang
this episode also once again showed us
the importance of the infinity stones no
matter what universe that we are in and
we are all very familiar with the
process of retrieving the stones but
that leads us to our second topic of
today
how did thanos get the soul stone
because in our universe thanos had to
sacrifice gamora to get the stone on
vormir but in this episode we saw a
thanos with the soul stone and gamora
still alive and fighting with the
sovereign so how did thanos in this
universe get the soul stone and what did
he have to sacrifice
nebula i just want to yell it out before
the elephant in the room the elephant in
the room i think the only dollar left
the only daughter
uh i think nebula but for a rogue theory
i don't think he ever kidnapped gamora
in this universe i think he only had
nebula
so
i think i think gamora still would have
been gamora without her father i think
she still would have saw what was
happening in the world and been like i
want to make a difference because this
woman has determination and she wants to
change the world somehow uh somehow so i
think she still would have been our
crime-fighting like fist to cuff bounty
hunter that she like
that we see her doing with her team
still i think they would have been like
she would have eventually been picked up
or it would have been a situation where
like she captured them and then they
were like we can go fight these things
together and she would have done it as
well and she would have been like we
need to defeat this guy thanos who's
destroying all the planets um and i
think so i think this world we don't
have a gamora related to thanos i think
we have just nebula and he sacrificed
his only daughter
the one and only
boom what if he did did he still wipe
out half of gamora's planet that would
be i was like i didn't want him to in
this theory because it was sad but i
mean that's probably what the mcu would
do they would still have her be like the
one child that was hidden and he killed
her family and have a drac storyline of
like killed my family and i have to go
fight him
um so yeah or maybe he just stole like a
different little girl named rebecca or
something and he took rebecca
what if nebula what if in this universe
nebula and gamora were sisters and he
stole nebula and gamora was like this
and
gamora was like i need my sister back
that's how i feel like she would say
there's a lot of ways this can go when
you have multiple universes limitless
she could
nebula could be a chicken in one we
don't know wait so timeout so you think
that um thanos sacrificed nebula but in
the movies it doesn't seem like thanos
and nebula really got along it doesn't
seem like nebula no like pedals didn't
even like 100 but because he had gamora
but in this universe nebula is his only
one and he still treats her like a pile
of crap but you know how like he made it
i don't know if this comes across as
this to anybody else maybe but
and it's not good it's not good how i'm
gonna say this um he
it wasn't tough love that he gave nebula
but it was like
you need to be the best like my children
need to be the best so i still think he
would treat nebula in that sense where
she just like how gamora was like you
don't love me you there's no one you
love who are you gonna throw over this
cliff i think the same with nebula
nebula would be like you don't love me
you took out my eye and he's just like i
did it for like for you to be strong
because his reasoning and justification
is so misaligned that i think he thinks
he's doing good obviously when he's
clearly not so
in this universe he does love nebula so
it's like so it's like a a love from
like an abuser's yeah
it's genuine love but like it's not the
good it's not
clearly it's not love but to him it is
to him it's not love it's not love well
he only replaced nebulous parts because
she was getting beat by gum yeah and if
there's
not another sister or if it's just
nebula there's no one to beat her so
uh to beat her in combat or whatever uh
so then thanos theoretically maybe isn't
even like piecemealing around maybe
she's still 100 whole think that
thanos
then sacrificed like mama like like
grandma or something i think thanos
there we go is that it mima
thanos
don't even worry about it
[Laughter]
it's cold like bank of america but it
doesn't look like yeah
[Laughter]
are you the manager
i'd like to speak to you for a second
immediately
so yeah that's what i think happened i i
think thanos just sacrificed me ma
okay
i mean it's true he could have other
family that he cares about i do like
that i've got i've got he loves his
meemaw i've got two rose theories on
this one uh okay
we see him show up on earth alone
where's the black order i i think he
tossed one of them
until
yeah the one he liked the most that he
saved her last was corvus glaive yes who
he was in love with
and we know that proxima and clovis had
a thing but that was just a cover-up for
thanos and corvus glaives true love that
they had for each other he was the last
one he tossed over the clip that's
that's one of my theories my other
theory is in this timeline on vormir
it's not
red skull it's it's the lady death and
he showed up there with all the other
stones already and she except for the
mind stone obviously so he shows up
there with four stunts and she's
impressed she's impressed by the jewelry
he woos her he whines her he dines her
and he gets that soul stone without
sacrificing anything tonight's death are
you kidding me brandon that's what i
said that's why i think what happened
here because we all
admitted when you were in the theater
and you saw uh infinity war for the
first time and you saw the like floating
black stuff you thought oh they're gonna
have the lady death here she is we're
gonna see her and then it was red skull
and you're like well that's just as good
i like that but uh i think in this this
weird what if episode it wasn't red
skull there it was the lady death and he
he schmoozed her you know what i mean
he's got he's got the charm he turned
the charm no these were all amazing
theories but i think i want to give a
thousand points each the ladies but 2
000 points to brandon oh yeah
but now it is time for my favorite part
of the show the rogue question and
today's real question is we finally have
a release date for disney plus book of
boba fett and the new series will be
coming to the stream platform on
december 29th so please pitch me your
rogest theories on what the show will be
even about because we don't really know
at this point i've got i've got a very
rogue theory for you on what the book
okay book of boba fett is gonna be about
okay this is you know i think disney
plus is ready to make a show that's a
little more light-hearted a little more
of a sitcom a situational comedy if you
will
uh in the book of boba fett okay in this
one boba fett's moved into jabba's
abandoned palace he's taking it over and
he's turning it into a bed and breakfast
okay and everyone from around the galaxy
is going to finally be coming to
tatooine and have a nice place to stay
so the book of boba fett it's like a
guest book people show up they write
their names in so each week will be like
a guest you know a new special guest
star is going to come stay
at jabba's palace and tan to on tatooine
it's going to be like the love boat and
it's going to be a really fun adventure
we're going to have funny hijinks there
will be some lasers yes there'll be some
shooting and some uh some lightsabers
but it it's gonna be about uh boba fett
running a bed and breakfast on tatooine
i like that though i would have given
you extra points if you said boba tea i
feel like that would be very fitting
they'll have some
the youth don't care about the boba i
would love to see this be
a very much a classic western
style so think
you know maybe something like a fist
full of dollars for a few dollars more
type style boba fett's gonna gonna come
in a tattooing
um
and
is going to
you know we're gonna have some of those
nice like shots of of him like you know
hands-on weapon we're gonna get like uh
this town ain't big enough for the two
of us type situation with jabba and he's
basically going to go after
jabba the hutt and his like whole crime
syndicate and it's gonna get
real zesty and real like westerny
there's gonna be yeah there's gonna be
like i don't know there's gotta be
gravestone somewhere i just love western
so i'm really just
laying it in here but i would love to
see that uh when we get to this part of
rogue theory jessica always has a silly
answer but this is gonna be the first
time where i'm dead ass serious
i think the book of boba
will be
book of boba tea
will be about
just the
history culture religion what you what
have you of the mandalorians because i
think after seeing the mandalorian one
thing that we were really interested in
were the other mandalorians and how they
the entire time were like you can't show
your face but it's like you live by that
code you're one of those mandalorians
we're the mandalorians that don't live
by that code so i think there's
different factions of the mandalorians
that we want to see
more of and i think that's what the book
of boba will be about is more so
how
even if it's mainly circled around boba
fett how the other mandalorians what
they believed in and what they see and
how they see it because i think living
by a code is good but then also
recognizing that that code is
outdated is even better um so i think
we'll see more mandalorians and see
their way of living and how different it
can be and some might just be genuinely
bad people
yes i am
that's mine okay so like sort of like
the book of mormon but the book of
mandalore
well if it's like a cool new youth
pastor who shows up and it's like hey
you know it doesn't have to be like it's
always been you know we can take our
shoes off in church
he turns that chair
will shuster from delaware yeah yeah
well these were all amazing theories uh
but i'm going to give 1 000 points to
brandon for his boba bed and breakfast
idea it's very funny um i'm gonna give 2
000 points to angelica for her western
theory because
it just makes sense for
boba fett to be a western because it's
very much in line but i'm gonna give
three thousand points to jess because
mandel the mandalorian series and the
mandalorians as a whole are very
religious and like it's all i do like
the the story of the culture of the
mandalorians and i feel like they will
dive into that in that series and i do
want
so
3000 points to jess which i believe
makes jess our winner if i'm not
mistaken it does it does
mt i'll slip you a five later
thank you
we agreed on 10. what the hell is this
that wasn't our deal
i feel like lando that is it for our
episode of rogue theory i want to thank
brandon angelica and jessica clemens for
joining us today thank you guys for
joining me this episode you can follow
all of them on their socials and please
support them with everything that
they're doing uh jessica and angelica
are amazing twitch streamers so please
follow them
until one day brandon will stream as
well i i ordered the hot tub and i will
be on stream as soon as it arrives oh my
god all right irl street brandon
right now
oh god i opened a bunch of windows oh
god
oh my god kappa folks kappa here we go i
don't know i don't know vloggers and you
can follow me mastertainment and you can
follow new rockstars wherever we are on
social media and please hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com so you can get cool
new nerd shirts so you all your friends
can respect you alright thank you all
for watching and we'll see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]
you